une pêche tourisme avec comme
destinations vedettes cuba qui a battu
son record de fréquentation l'an dernier
2 millions de visiteurs mais ce sont
essentiellement les quartiers du passé
colonial qui ont été rénovés la
population de ne profite que très peu de
retombées économiques du tourisme
christian matin les portes des wagons
palace est superbe couleur bleue le
centre colonial de la havane a revêtu
ses plus beaux atours pour accueillir
ces touristes français et voilà ce qui
les attire ici à cuba l'exotisme un
petit peu le côté rétro des voitures
américaines
les façades classées et la chaleur
forcément cuba la carte postale attiré
l'an dernier 2 millions de visiteurs un
record et l'argent du tourisme est
aujourd'hui la principale ressource du
pays
un pactole qui a permis à la havane de
faire peau neuve
classé par l'unesco le centre historique
est en rénovation depuis dix ans une
opération trop lente pour certains cas
un peu surpris quand même par tous et
c'est super beau bâtiment la lisant dans
un très beau bâtiment mais il faut quand
même un peu à l'abandon
la plupart des bâtiments tous propriété
de l'état ont été en effet laissé à
l'abandon pendant 35 ans une course
contre la montre est maintenant engagée
sur le mans power a comparé à
aujourd'hui seulement 30% du centre
historique a pu être restauré
le problème c'est qu'il faudrait
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus d'argent pour
pouvoir achever la totalité de cette
rénovation
à quelques mètres des circuits
touristiques voici l'autre visage de la
havane depuis dix ans maria habite avec
ses deux filles et son mari dans cette
masure
elle est bien allé voir les délégués du
quartier mais sans succès
imaginez lankais
elle m'a envoyé à tournon tech ils m'ont
dit qu'il n'y avait même pas de carton
chez trou dans le toit et stopper les
fuites d'eau n'a pas de moyens c'est ce
qu'on m'a dit il ya pas de moyens le
danger c'est que tout ça s'écroule
j'ai un papier qui dit que la maison est
déclarée inhabitable pour ces cubes à la
manne touristique risque d'être un
mirage pour encore longtemps
seule une petite partie du coeur
historique de la havane a retrouvé son
éclat et au rythme actuel
au moins vingt ans seront nécessaires
pour achever cette réhabilitation